before we get going if you enjoy what we
do on spectator tv
then subscribe to our youtube channel
click the button at the bottom of this
video and then tap the bell icon
to make sure you never miss an episode
and if you want to subscribe to the
magazine
take up our 12 issues for 12 pound offer
you'll get three months of the spectator
in print
and online for just 12 pounds plus we'll
give you a 20 pound amazon voucher
completely free just go to spectator dot
co dot uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
[Music]
harold mass writes in this week's
magazine about china's horrific
manhunt of the weaker muslims the
minority group
which beijing has been imprisoning in
so-called re-education camps in xinyang
is now being hunted down by the chinese
communist party abroad
specifically in countries like turkey
and dubai that were previously safe
havens
harold is on the show now harold thank
you for joining us on spectator tv
in your piece you write about how the
ccp is following us around the world
and then imprisoning them sending them
back to internment camps in china
can you tell us more about what's going
on yeah thank you the campaign actually
against the
uis which happens in china in
western china it's already quite known
but
what i think is interesting about this
situation is
that china's expanding the situation and
this massive
crackdown and and some say
like ethnical genocide against uigurus
now on a worldwide scale and uh
shockingly this happens especially in
countries like in
muslim countries like egypt like united
arab emirates like saudi arabia and
there i spoke to people who
families who lost contact to the loved
ones who
just disappeared and this have been
transported back
to china and there vanished in some of
the
camps or in prison and in your piece for
the magazine this week
you detail some of those examples what
has the weaker experience been like
the experiences these are not from
my knowledge and also from lots of
interviews i did with ue gurus
in germany in other countries in
kazakhstan
these are not people who were
politically who
adjecti who do any kind of work against
china these are just normal families who
try to work who
who in dubai and do just normal work
and suddenly they get a call from the
local police in this case it was in
in in dubai um a couple
and the guy was asked to to call report
to the police station he's been he's
been living in dubai for many many years
and there he was arrested and his wife
had not
had not a chance to talk to him again he
she just saw him there
and a few weeks or months later he was
extradited to china and um most probably
as has been there sent to an um
re-education camp
like hundreds of thousands people there
as well so we're not talking about
dissidents we're not talking about
political active people or whatever
we're just talking about normal families
and people who just disappeared in this
case the wife
she has not heard from her husband for
more than three years and of course she
talks to the chinese authorities
to the e to the um to the authorities in
dubai but she never gets an answer
and she herself had to flee as well
because this country became so
dangerous for um insecure for uighur
people that she had to flee to
turkey there's obviously no situation
where these actions taken by the ccp
would be justified
but this feels like an important point
to emphasize they're not just targeting
those who are vocally opposed to the
government or actively campaigning
against it
they're essentially targeting any and
all weakers going about their normal
lives
so in other words absolutely no weaker
is safe
exactly and and if this would be only
one case or two case you could argue
maybe the chinese government has some
knowledge which we don't have
but i talked over the years to to dozens
of families
um in mainly in countries close to china
and kazakhstan where where the kazakh
people
same as we go same from the region of
xinjiang getting
sent to these camps and these are people
who
are just sometimes some are retired
have been retired and and they get a
call
and say oh there's some question about
your former job please come and report
to us
then they go back to xinjiang and they
disappear in a camp some went there for
family reunions some
one couple i talked to went for for for
a wedding
and um the guy never came back and
so these are just normal people and some
of them are even which is
uh ironically some of them are even had
been in the past supporters
of of of the government and had been
members of the communist party
but just that you're a muslim and just
that you're like member of the of the
uigurus or kazakh people in xinjiang
makes you basically um brings you in
danger to
getting sent to these camps you report
that some people are being
taken from places that have previously
been a refuge to uighur muslims
places like turkey and egypt what's
changed
turkey is still in a sense the most
refuge for for uighur people and and the
most important country for uigurus
um to to to go there and live because
uh uighur culture and language is very
close to the turkish they basically can
understand them
again understand turkish language and
the culture is very close
and um but these other countries you
just mentioned
there there had been always a few
thousand people we
we were people who lived there and
apparently
and quite obviously the chinese
government is using its
power it's it's even growing economic
influence and whatever means that they
have
to to put pressure on these countries
and lots of pressure
to extradite these people back to to
china in some cases
chinese police people people from the
secret
police from china have been coming to
these churches have been coming to egypt
for example
and interviewing these people and
questioning these people in the
in in in the prison and then before
they've been sent back
so what is happening that china is
basically expanding its campaign
against uighurs which is is happening
for more than three years um now
in xinjiang on a global scale and the
space
for uighurs to live is getting smaller
and smaller
because are not so many countries left
one sentence may be about
about turkey because this is still the
most important place where
people can live you have to imagine
these people don't have passports
because they have chinese passports but
china stopped long
long time ago to renew these passports
so you
they don't have means to travel they
they basically stateless in a sense
and in turkey they've been safe but now
we can see there's lots of pressure on
turkey from the chinese side
to sign like some kind of agreements
where which would um make uigurus
bring them in the situation that they
have been sending them from turkey as
well to
to back to china as if this weren't
distressing enough you also report
worryingly
that the chinese government is using
official bodies like the international
criminal police organization
to hunt down the uyghur muslims
how is the west allowing this to happen
um this this interpol you're mentioning
china is doing this for many years and
they're intensifying this basically
misusing international bodies and
international organizations
for bringing these people and for for
hunting for this kind of manhunt if you
want
and one prominent case is is the
the president of the world we google
congress which is the exile organization
this is not a political organization
they are based in germany
and and they are um this person like
dawkin either was a president
he was basically wanted by for more than
20 years by interpol
on the request on china and um to
and he was always when he traveled he
was in danger that he would go to some
country even
south korea and and then they've been
the risk of being sending back
the problem is that is international
organization
and they they don't check what the
member
states basically why they are hunting
somebody or why they
make a person like a wanted person and
if you like china want to misuse this
for political reason
then you have basically the situation
that people who
like talking easily for example he was
checked by the german government he's a
german citizen and he for
of course all the german secret service
and
everybody else was checking if he would
have some political
whatever he would be an activist or if
he would be like non-violent in any
sense
but they never there was never any proof
in this case
but still for he he was always at risk
being sending back
to china so is the west being lazy here
and in this case and to an extent which
could be deadly for people
uh by not checking china's power when it
abuses these international systems
to to to understand it's not only china
misusing for example
interpol in this case other other
authority in
authoring states also misuse the system
but china is doing this massively
um it's it's of course
european countries they check very
carefully and they never sendings
they who is if they get like a red
notice this is how it's called
from interpol somebody's wanted from
which country it's coming and if this is
a country which misuses this for
political reasons
and then um then they don't extradite
people
and um european countries have been
actually quite quite
open and they to for uigurus and there
have been a lot of
people have been accepted as refugees
so i think it's not that the governments
are blind and they're doing their part
but the reality is that china is getting
much more powerful and the countries
which have
financial um economic interest political
interests with china
especially now with this the covet
crisis and a lot of countries
which are economically maybe not so
strong which are politically or
economically
depending on china especially now the
kovic crisis
where china is using its vaccination and
vaccination programs to put
pressure on some countries then they
just have to choose
the pressure is getting more and more in
some countries some you mentioned
like egypt saudi arabia and the united
arab
emirates they they are changing their
policies
and basically they're handing over these
weaker people
to being sent back to china where they
disappear in the camps or even in prison
and turkey is now somewhere in the
middle and it
depends on how will turkey will react
and act
in the next few months if
turkey will still be like a safe place
for illegal people
and just to put into perspective what is
happening to the uyghurs when they
return
to china you've written for us before
highlighting the atrocities going on
inside these internment camps can you
tell us a bit about that
um china officially labels
these um these camps like at education
centers
in the beginning and and then when the
first information came out about this
camp system
china flatly denied that these camps are
happening but they are on such a big
scale and according to reports by
experts of the united nations and which
are quite credible
there are up to a million people being
held in these camps and so we're talking
about a huge system of
thousands of of of chemists like on a
huge scale
which have been built up and these these
camps are clearly visible through
satellite images some
even through photos from outside and of
course by the reports of people who
managed to escape who have family
members there
so we're talking about a huge massive
system
and in these camps these people are are
very strictly indoctrinated they they're
basically treated like
like criminals um they they they're not
allowed
to freely of course not eat not to to
leave but not even to talk
freely to meet people freely it's
basically like
living in prison but not only in prison
but being basically they have to sing
and
communist songs they have to praise the
leadership
they have denounced their religion and
they have to
basically accept that the
chinese culture and the chinese han
culture
is superior to their own culture they
have to learn chinese like putin
they're the main han chinese language
and which is just one part of basically
of a huge campaign
to eradicate the culture of these people
so
in the schools students are not allowed
to speak their own language anymore
um people are not allowed to dress in
the way they want
and apart from this in whole of xinjiang
and i
managed to travel for a few weeks um
undercover through this region and
um you have like police checks basically
every few hundred meters when you're in
the cities you have
visible police which to shock the people
and to scare them to frighten them
if you travel to xinjiang and i've been
based in china for more than 10 years
i've been to tibet in other regions but
what i saw there is is not comparable as
anything else i've seen
in the end it feels like a huge prison
itself if you travel through
um last question as we see more and more
graphic reports
like the one that you are highlighting
do you think pressure is going to grow
on china
to address this and to stop their attack
on the weaker population
i don't know um what
or what can be done to make china change
their policies
but i think the scale and of this
human rights violation and basically
this kind of
like trying to eradicate
the the culture and the identity of a
whole population
um in this region is um
it's not something where you can which
you can just ignore or which you can
just
go over to business as normal and you
have to
there have been things happening that
that international companies
like for example in the closing industry
they get their cotton from this region
and i think people have to think
if you as if your consumer for example
in in
in europe right now i think it's it's
worth not to think only about
environmental things when you buy
products but it's although
so important that you think about
political consequences a lot of products
come from there
um this campaign what china is doing
there it's not
like a short it doesn't look like a
short-term campaign it doesn't look
something they started a few months and
might stop in a few months there's
massive infrastructure you have to
imagine thousands of camps like this
electronic supervision with
streets going there and it's a huge
system of camps
which apparently is is
has been built to stay there for a long
time
so this seems to be what we're seeing
right now the
long-term solution that china has in
mind for the uighurs
and it's difficult to see a change there
because it's connected to the top
leadership in beijing
to xi jinping himself who gave basically
the orders to
to to act in this way and to suppress
the people there in this way
so politically it would be a huge
change for china and it's not so easy to
imagine right now
[Music]
you